hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from yesterday's title
Tuesday it's a round three game between
Magnus Carlson and Paulina shuvalova and
Magnus Carlson won the event with a
staggering 10 and a half out of 11 uh
these are the final standings but um
even though that's a very impressive
result for for Magnus even for Magnus
this is the game that you guys requested
from round three so you can see uh okay
first he defeated Yan ree then Raven
then poina shalva then and ralo ariari n
sarin only one who got a draw against
Magnus is ala fja then he defeated
bullet and Blitz expert Serge Shalo then
Jeffrey Shan then Yang Shuda and in the
final round with the black pieces he
defeated Leon Aran H but now why did you
guys request this game so much well it
features a spectacular finishing move
and also it features a line that I'm
sure after you watch this game uh you
will use and abuse to its fullest to win
many of your Blitz and bullet games on
online it features a very rare line
against the caroan uh so let's dive
straight into it so Magnus had the white
pieces and he opened with Ponto E4 and
if you if you've noticed I've added the
clock times I know you guys have been
requesting that now I don't always have
access to clock times for some of the
historical games but for online Blitz
Games and if there if the online if the
tournament is uh uh played on a digital
board I do have access to clock times or
if it's an online game I don't mind
including them so also you you're free
to comment on that do do you like them
do do you prefer not having them uh
let's check it out so C6 poina goes for
the caroan defense and now Knight to E2
okay so not going for the standard the
D4 or Knight to F3 against the caroan we
have D5 and now Pawn to E5 sort of the
advanced variation but we doubted the
pawn on D4 we have Bishop to F5 of
course she wants to play E6 and um and
get her B Bishop out of the uh cage
Knight to G3 going after the bishop
Bishop G3 Bishop G6 and now H4 a sort of
the tall variation against the caroan
but without the pawn on D4 and okay
what's the what's the big deal here H6
we have Pawn to H5 now challenging the
bishop the bishop to H7 and usually in a
t variation you would see Bishop D3 then
Bishop captures Queen captures but here
there's a Pawn on D2 so you can't really
play Bishop to D3 you could however
transpose with um something like Pawn to
D4 Pawn to D6 and then Bishop to D3 but
not for this game Magnus as this is a
three minute Blitz game Magnus plays
Pawn to E6 and okay it's a known line in
the advanced variation um or or a known
Pawn push which you can meet many
different ways and I'm going to show you
how to treat this if you actually play
this with the black pieces you have to
play Queen to D6 and once white captures
you will capture on F7 but it's not a
problem your king is very safe here and
now after Pawn to D4 you will strike
with Pawn to E5 and a trade uh is good
for black and if you try Bishop to D3
then you even Advance the pawn to E4 and
it will be black who will be asking the
questions here however after after E6
she went for f captures and E6 grabbing
the pawn and now let's see how Magnus
handles this position he plays Pawn to
D4 we have Knight to F6 and now Bishop
to D3 okay she captures it's very well
known that you should do this Knight to
A6 and now Knight to D2 We have Queen to
B6 there is a game where Queen to A5 was
played in the year 2000 Yosef par played
it against Lazlo Sabo and won a very
nice game but here Paulina goes for
Queen to B6 and it is not as of move 11
that we have a completely new game and
magnus's position is already straight up
winning so let's see how Magnus does it
we have Queen to G6 with check uh King
to D7 and now Knight to F3 uh preparing
Knight to E5 check to take away valuable
squares from the black king queen to B5
stopping Magnus from castling and now
Pawn to A4 taking away squares from the
black queen queen B4 checks C3 and queen
to B3 we have Knight to E5 with check
King to C7 and now Magnus castles we
have Pawn to B B6 uh trying to get some
more squares for the black king and
maybe uh get the pieces into the game
Queen to F7 now going after the E6
weakness we have Rook to d8 as there
really is no uh way to defend the pawn
Now Pawn to A5 uh giving up the pawn to
open up the a file for for the white
Rooks so Pawn to B5 and now Bishop to F4
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries towards the black king So
King to B7 and now Queen captures on E6
going after that C6 Pawn so Rook to D6
attacking the queen and defending the
pawn queen back to F7 and now Knight to
C7 uh REM maneuvering the knights trying
to get them into the game now A6 checked
by Magnus and you could capture with the
Knight but then again you give the a
file to the white Rooks and the black
king will just get the destroyed here so
King to B6 and now Magnus plays Knight
to F5 attacking The Rook on D6 and you
can't really do anything about it these
two sores are covered by the Knight if
you put the Rook here then just Knight
to G6 goes after this rook and then if
you move it you lose the bishop so you
really have to give up something so she
goes Queen to C2 gives up the exchange
here Magnus captures it we have Knight
captures on D6 and now e captures on D6
and the position is completely winning
for Magnus he has a beautiful Force
Checkmate here not just one he has
several beautiful checkmates here uh but
you guys of course will uh be the judge
of that and try to find it the most
Spectacular One so feel free to pause
the video and win the game in the
coolest way possible for Magnus probably
give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
either Queen sacrifice and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
Magnus played Queen captures on F6 uh I
will I will explain why but uh there's
even a nicer one and that is Queen to D7
offering a queen like this because okay
it's nice to forcefully give up your
queen but uh giving giving up your queen
like this where your opponent actually
has a way way of declining it uh also
you know not to throw away and the point
is that now if Knight captures Knight
captures and D7 is just Checkmate all of
the squares are taken away from the
black King Pawn covers B7 and if you
don't capture let's say you capture the
Knight then you play this very nice
Queen to C8 move and there is no defense
against Queen to B7 Checkmate uh but it
was not the one that Magnus chose after
this Knight captures some D6 move um and
uh Queen captures on F6 uh he went for
Queen captures on F6 now of course if
the queen is captured then Knight to D7
is again Checkmate so Pina played D
captures on E5 but now Magnus just plays
Queen captures on E5 going for Queen to
C7 Checkmate so Knight captures on A6
and now how do you go after the black
king of course you continue happily
sacrificing Rook captures on A6 with
check King captures and Rook to A1 with
check and he was in this position on
move 29 that PO shalva resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh you either start giving up pieces
like Queen to A4 Bishop to A3 which only
postpone Checkmate or you go King to B6
um sorry King to B7 and uh now there's
of course just Queen to B8 Checkmate so
that's why she resigned but yeah uh very
nicely done by Magnus and I'm sure that
uh uh if you guys were not aware of this
line maybe treating the caroan this way
not going for D4 but just E5 and then
continuing like you've already played D4
uh and then you know getting this tricky
position with E6 and if your opponent
doesn't know that it's okay to to allow
white to capture on F7 you might get a
very dangerous attack and U you might
win win win many bullet or Blitz Games I
might even try this in my rapid Conquest
that I'm doing on a daily basis if I if
I face the caroan although I I have been
enjoying playing E4 and D4 I might give
this Knight to E2 E5 line a try it does
look like uh you know it it's possible
to take down a very strong opponent with
this and yeah now that we have access to
clock times you can see that Magnus uh
ends the game uh sorry not here Magnus
ended the game uh with two minutes
uh and 14 seconds on the clock uh so
didn't really take all that much as uh
you know the position was very very hard
to play for black and it was easier to
find moves and it's always easier to
find moves when attacking than when
defending and you can see poina ended
the game with 17 seconds on the clock so
took really a lot of effort to to find
the moves that sort of defend the
position but we've said that the
position was already lost on move 11 so
not not an easy one uh so yeah once
again thank you guys for suggesting such
a beautiful game as usual you can use
hashtag suggestion when suggesting a
game because that's how I filter the
comments every right you know give me
all the comments that contain hashtag
suggestion and then I get your
suggestions like this wonderful game
here uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it and that this line will
help you win many Blitz and bullet games
online uh I would like to thank David
gasparian grn the maximite chess club
Huga boy on Spotify and the r schaer for
your contribution to my Channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestion such as
this one and continuing to cover
everything that's happening in the Chess
World uh so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day